this is Mike Francesa and I'm here to
answer the internet this episode is
brought to you by bare bottom clothing
stick around to the end for more details
would you rather get pegged by Randy
Johnson a Randy Johnson Festival on the
ribs hit by Ray Lewis or punched in the
face by Floyd Merriweather I would
rather get punched by Floyd that
wouldn't hurt good defensive fighter one
of the easiest and hardest positions in
all the sports
uh the easiest position in sports
professionally I don't think there is
one you know I don't think there is one
I mean if you consider backup
quarterback a position I mean anytime
you're going to be on the bench you
don't play anything's easy but on the
field I don't think there really is one
I think I think I think it takes a lot
of talent to play any position in any
sport what do you think the hardest is
the hardest is quarterback if you go to
any sporting event ever which would it
be
the best run sporting event I've ever
been to is the Kentucky Derby amazing
how they move things and how there's no
lines and there's 150 000 people the
most exciting event I've ever been at
was the giant Bill Super Bowl wide right
forever in Tampa with the cloaked in the
atmosphere of the Gulf War Whitney
Houston national anthem uh that was the
perfect sporting event and almost the
perfect game no turnovers in the game
that is the most memorable sporting
event I ever went to the most dramatic
intense sporting event I've ever been at
was Rangers Devils seventh game
at the Garden
in the
Conference Finals was the most intense I
ever felt a building in my life is there
one you you didn't go to that you wish
you could have the no I've been to
everything I I've been lucky I've been
there I never wanted to go to the
Indianapolis 500 when it was real what
about maybe like well I see a secretary
of race I mean I wasn't there for the
Belmont I would I mean I can give you
ones if I could pick a sporting event
that I could do a remote at it would
have been Ali Frazier Martha March 8th
1971. if dog and I had been doing Mike
and the mayor dog we would have been
Ringside at one o'clock in an empty
Garden
and done our show and watched the place
thought to open watch it fill up and be
able to just just be cloaked in the
intensity of that night there were stars
everywhere from Frank Sinatra to Kirk
Douglas to Bert Lancaster that all the
way down the line and it was Ali's
comeback obviously he had had two fights
before that leading up to Frazier the
two undefeated great Champions that's
the event I would have loved to do a
remote for would you rather be the best
receiver in the NFL but drop the
game-winning pass in the Super Bowl be
the best player in the NBA missed two
free throws to lose game seven in the
finals I wouldn't want any part of
either okay
if they throw me the ball I'm catching
it okay I'm making a free throw too I'm
telling you that I'm clutch I'm telling
you would you rather be able to throw
105 or dunk
I'd rather be able to throw 105. yeah
more intimidating
a lot of people can dunk a lot of bad
players can dunk
who is your favorite movie villain not a
movie but a mini-series
Falcon Eddie and Rich Man Poor Man the
best bad guy ever and if you don't know
it check it out it was the classic early
miniseries it was cool classic
miniseries that made television The
Thornbirds and Rich Man Poor Man
they were the first real long miniseries
Falcon Eddie was the best bad guy ever
in Rich Man Poor Man check it out
sometime when was that
70s who would win a fight Yao Ming or
Allen Iverson Allen Iverson do you think
so no question really no question I mean
not even close not even close do you
think it would be like not even close
level of meanness is such so different
if you could eliminate one state sports
teams proa College what state would it
be
I tell you I don't hate any teams I
don't really like I don't I'm a Yankee
fan I don't dislike the Red Sox I
actually like I love filming folks my
favorite Stadium
um I don't have a hatred of any team so
I I would I wouldn't take anybody out I
I'm glad they're all here I enjoy sports
and I enjoy the team so I don't have
anybody I really hate would you rather
hit a home run as a pitcher score a goal
as a hockey goalie or a TDS alignment
um or any of the most rare things I
think I think a goal as as a scoring a
goal as a goalie is really cool I like
that one
I've always liked that one I think
that's fascinating I would say that one
it just happened this past season with
the Bruins goal yeah I think that I
think that's really you know everyone
always Roots so hard for that I I would
love that one and what you don't realize
how it carries so then for the rest of
the season whenever he got the puck on
the stick people go crazy yeah
absolutely this last question is brought
to you by bare bottom clothing bare
bottoms expanded line of everyday
apparel is perfect for guys like me who
want a classic stylish look with clothes
that fit right and are comfortable those
three things come together and that's
what bare bottom is they've got t-shirts
they've got long sleeve tees they've got
hoodies they've got joggers that look
like jeans that they're comfortable
they're also stylish and you can wear
them out they've got polos shorts every
single type of clothing that regular
guys need that'll look good fit you
right and be comfortable go to
barebottomclothing.com ATI and get free
shipping on your first shipment today
also for each bare bottom item you
purchase they will donate a meal to a
child in need that's
barebottomclothing.com ATI could LeBron
beat any NHL player in a fight no
no does not want any part of them
absolutely no way they grow up fighting
absolutely that that's why they're all
missing teeth okay no you don't want any
part of that
you sir thank you thank you for watching
answer the internet please subscribe to
the channel comment below on other
celebrities you'd like to see and make
sure you hit the Bell to get
notifications when new episodes come out